it's sort of
it's a long story like the origin of the
game is a long story right so
[Music]
the variance that payday 2 has
is so unique to the game a lot of
variety
there is always something
that makes you come back to the game
okay do i want to have a little army of
sentry guns i can do that do i want to
be a sniper that
can take out 10 people with one shot i
can do that instead
and just being able to play with your
friends and sort of just like being a
bad guy there's not that many very much
games like it it is a game where you've
got 20 plus characters to pick from
you've got all these you know different
weapons you can choose and different
skill sets it caters to about every play
style physically possible
[Music]
2008
we went bankrupt that nine
nine yep yeah we did a bunch of games
and then
most of them sucked so we went bankrupt
and
that led to us um
trying our hand at just well we're
starting a new company first yeah we
went from 250 people yeah something like
that yeah starting over at we were eight
yeah something like that
[Music]
and we borrowed uh this
uh basement
and had it out as our office yeah we
bought it from uh fat shark yeah fat
shark were kind enough another developer
yeah
it was their warehouse
we had a small kitchen uh with a
microwave oven and if someone turned it
on the power
usually but yeah good ideas came from
that anyway so so very happy to kind of
have that
moment in our
our development
it didn't start with payday it didn't
start with
actually being a heisting game either
me and a guy called
ilya was trying to get a an fps
up and running with the team
we're like fooling around with that
trying to get psyched up but i had no
energy to do like
sci-fi stuff so
um
we just
i guess i just like brushed off the the
old
heist
theme again
we know there are a lot of good movies
about it but there are not really any
good games
being made around that topic
yeah the idea was to to allow to make a
game where you're you can
live that sort of fantasy you can be a
robert de niro's character yeah in in
heat and you can run into the bank and
scream everybody got the bar down and
then you see the civilians throw
themselves to the ground and
and you sort of
hunker down around the
the vault and you're drilling through
the metal and then the the police are
sort of barricading the building and
swats are coming through the skylights
through with uh
you know rappelling down on ropes and
yeah the chaos and the action
i think a lot of us can relate to this
idea of breaking free from commitments
and the pressure and everything that
goes into daily life with with work and
other aspects that are part of our
routines and whatnot and just breaking
free from that and leaving a life of
crime guided by kind of your own just
sheer willpower and
not letting anything stop you i think
that is very
very much an escapist fantasy that's
very powerful and then looking at payday
as a game i mean it's uh
it's incredibly well conceived in terms
of its foundations the core experience
the the formula of of the game i think
is very very strong
[Music]
i think the character creation was
basically
and the way we portray them i think
i have to say it's all you simon
well we the thing is with
how wolf really ended up in the game is
we would record placeholder voices
and we we were standing in the office
yeah with a mattress in a corner
facing the mattress with a microphone
in front of us
just this makeshift sort of recording
booth
in in payday your voice is sort of a
weapon as well like you you press your
mouse button and you shoot
uh and then you you press that i think
it's f
and then you scream and that's also sort
of a weapon
and it turned out that
oath has a absolutely phenomenal
screaming voice come with me paxton
we're gonna make it so we the
placeholder the placeholder all their
voices we were like we can't we can't
replace off
hurry hurry
i guess the argument that got me over to
that to you know doing it is basically
if simon was doing the the
story
sort of guiding voice and we had at
least one
um
one team member from from from our team
yeah but one character being played we
could always like do fillers and quick
pickups and that kind of thing i would
infuse respect in anyone they'll be back
for more than a minute
at that point obviously we didn't know
that it was going to be a rather popular
game and that it would be a sequel
but i just did the voice and i thought
that this voice has to cut through the
the noise and the you know the gunfire
and everything
and it's it's going to be distorted
because it's in your
earpiece sort of and it needs to cut
through uh so i didn't want to use my
normal voice i went up here and i added
a little bit of like hoarseness or like
yeah so that the distortion would sort
of hook on to that sort of raspy
raspiness of the voice and be more like
a sharper sound that cuts through
but it's really
it's it's uh i hate doing the voice i
hope we can work together again in the
future
we went to e3
in 2011 we had not announced that we
were making this game i don't even think
that we had announced that we existed as
a company
we had
a printed merchandise
with a
stone cold as logo we had i believe we
had coffee cups we had t-shirts and and
we had a couple of other things the uh
sony online entertainment called us
basically
one or two days before
us going to to this uh to this event
and said that
we
can't use stone cold and the reason is
because there is a
american wrestler
named stone cold
uh and uh so yeah we had to change it
and we were like battling on the or like
trying to come up with a good name and
we just bounced ideas around like there
was a lot of ideas uh we wanted to get
the idea of uh
heisting into the title maybe that it
was a foreplay coop and so on and i
think we
i think it was martin just gave up on us
and walked walks out of the room we were
in the kitchen
we spent like two hours or something i
can't remember and then we had some good
ideas like crime waves yeah yeah and uh
and then he pops back in
i blurted out payday payday
that's my memory
yeah
everyone
kind of agreed yeah hey dude it works
you can do that
i never had to go back and change
everything in the game as well to you to
actually save payday instead of stone
cold and and
make new merch
[Music]
the past 10 years during payday's
lifetime starbucks has changed in many
ways and we've improved but more so the
people inside the studio those of us who
some of us have remained during the past
10 years some newers i think what's so
important to realize is that everything
we've been through with pedia and
everything else has shaped us as a team
and has
formed us into this group of people that
not only care about each other and our
own experiences and and
making sure that we can make the best
games that we can together but also
about the players and and the journey
they've taken through all of it
[Music]
i think uh payday's popularity stems out
of two things really one is us the
developers behind the game
the thoughts we have about the designs
where to take it what features to add
and not and the other part is the
community what they'd like to see and
how well we interact with each other i
think through that
is you get payday
[Music]
you